اهلا بكم من جديد شركه
الامريكيه هي واحده من كبرى الشركات
المختصه بالمنظومات الدفاعيه الطائره
وتحديدا المنظومات المسيره مؤخرا وقعت هذه
الشركه اتفاق تعاون مع شركه سرب السعوديه
لتطوير مسيره ابقيق ابقيق هي مسيره تم
تصنيعها بالكامل محليا وبحقوق ملكيه فكريه
سعوديه خالصه
التطور الكبير والحيوي في مجال الطائرات
المسيره جعل الكثير من الدول تسعى لتعزيز
قدراتها في هذا المشاكل المملكه العربيه
السعوديه مؤخرا باتت تبدي اهتماما كبيرا
بتطوير هذا المجال سواء عبر شركات محليه
او حتى عبر اتفاقيات وشراكات مع شركات
دوليه كبرى عامله في هذا المجال مؤخرا
قامت بتوقيع اتفاقيه مع شركه
وهي احدى الشركات التي تم دمجها ايضا مع
شركه ريسون الامريكيه حول هذه الاتفاقيه
وكذلك ما هي القيمه المضافه التي تشكلها
هذه الاتفاقيه بالنسبه للسعوديه وكذلك
بالنسبه للشركه معنا السيد كولين ماهولي
رئيس قسم التطوير الاعمال وشركات
الاستراتيجيه بشركه كولنس ايروسبيس
الامريكيه مؤخرا وقعتم مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اتفاقيه شراكه بشان تطوير طائرات
مسيره ما هي القيمه المضافه التي سيشكلها
او ستشكلها هذه الاتفاقيه بالنسبه
للسعوديه وكذلك ما هي التكنولوجيا التي من
ممكن ان يتم نقلها للسعوديه في هذا المجال
نحن فخورون جدا لتوقيع اتفاق مع شركه
السرب والعمل الذي يقومون به على
المنظومات الجويه غير الماهوله في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه انه في الحقيقه مزيج بين
الاستراتيجيه طويله الامد للشراكه من اجل
تطوير القدرات الجديده فعبر هذه الشراكه
سنعمل على تحقيق التكامل مع منظومه
للاستشعار كما سنعمل على منظومه الطيار
الالي بيكولو ووصلت البيانات اللاسلكيه اس
سي اي اس ار لهذه المنصه فجوهر هذه الجهود
هو العمل مع شركاء والشركات في دول الشرق
الاوسط مصر كولن يعني بمناسبه الشرق
الاوسط كما ذكرت ما هي خطتكم في الشرق
الاوسط خلال المرحله القادمه خاصه بان
هناك الان الكثير من الدول في هذه المنطقه
لا تتسعى لتوطين الصناعات الدفاعيه
والعسكريه بداخلها والى اي مدى لديكم يعني
ترحيب بمساله توطين التكنولوجيا او نقل
المعرفه ونقل الافكار لهذه الدول
مواطن
نحن نعمل في هذه المنطقه منذ عده عقود
واساس هذا النجاح هو اسلوب شراكاتنا مع
الصناعه لتحقيق رؤى الدول المتعدده مثال
على ذلك حاليا هو فضاء القتال ذي
الاتصالات متعدده النطاقات لان معاركنا
المستقبليه يجب ان تكون مرتبطه بشكل مباشر
بالمعلومات الانيه فمع توسعنا في المنطقه
نسعى لتنميه تجاربنا لكي نزود هذه القدرات
لاحتياجات المعارك المستقبليه
مستر كولن وعدتم في كولينز بتخفيض
الانبعاثات الكربونيه لطائرات المدنيه
بحلول عام 2050 لمستوى الصفر لكن ماذا عن
الطائرات الحربيه وكذلك هل سيؤثر هذا على
خططكم في الانتاج داخل الشركه ام لا اوكي
هذا هو عام الاستدامه في الامارات العربيه
المتحده وشركه كولينز متحمسه جدا للمساهمه
عبر جميع امكاناتها في تخفيض الانبعاثات
الكربونيه من الطائرات الى مستوى الصفر
فاذا ما تحدثنا عن قدرات الالكترونيات
للتحليق بفعاليه من النقطه الف الى النقطه
باء او قدرات هيكل الطائره لتخفيض وزنها
او حتى تنويع مصادر طاقه الطائره مثل
الهجين الكهربائي وصولا الى استخدام
الهيدروجين ووقود الطيران المستدام فكل
هذه الامور تساعد الطيران التجاريه
والعسكريه لخفض اثرها على البيئه
كانت واحده من الشركات المهمه في مجال
الالكترونيات والطيران على مستوى العالم
مؤخرا تم دمج الشركه مع شركه ريتون شركه
شركه بالتاكيد هي شركه كبيره لكن هناك
تحذيرات دائمه من عمليه الاستحواذ او
الدمج ما بين الشركات الصغيره والشركات
الكبيره وان هناك مخاوف ما لا يؤثر هذا
الامر على الصناعات الدفاعيه على مستوى
العالم انتم
فيس كيف تاثرتم بهذا الدمج وهل شكل لكم
قيمه مضافه ام لا
عمرو شركتنا الان ثلاثه اعوام منذ دمج
شركتي ريثيون تي سي وقد وفر لنا هذا الدمج
امكانيه هائله لاستكشاف جميع منتجاتنا
لجمع قدرات الشركتين بشكل سلس لكي نصل الى
المعادله الشهيره 1 + 1 = اكثر من اثنين
فاذا اخذنا بيئه العمليات متعدده النطاقات
فتشمل اجهزه الاستشعار والت واصل وتفسير
البيانات والعمل ولدينا اجزاء من شركتنا
تتعامل مع كل واحده من هذه المراحل
فالكفاءه الناجمه عن جمع كل ذلك ستكون
مثيره جدا